i thought you did a great job with this
um and before we get into it i've been
asking everybody the same two first
questions so i'm just gonna ask you
those
uh what tv series would you love to
guest star on
ah what tvc is what i love to guest star
on
um oh that's a really tough one i i mean
oh god i've been watching vikings i know
i'm a bit late to the game on that one
but i enjoyed that
just so cool those guys are you guys are
awesome they're making a sequel series
at netflix now so maybe you can get in
on that
yeah right for sure uh what movie
or movies do you think you've seen the
most
i think i've seen well it's probably
it's also between
aliens like the aliens uh
two and three are probably my favorite i
love one as well
um we're gonna talk about the others um
and then
um probably back to the future
is up there also with indiana jones uh
kind of watch those
a lot yeah i could talk about aliens all
day uh that movies are working too yes
so it's so good isn't it i mean yeah i
actually and three weirdly um you know
i mean the whole thing with three is
that they didn't even have a script
really they was making up as they went
along but
um fascinating and originally they were
going to have this planet that was
built of wood it was a mechanical planet
run by like monks it was kind of
crazy anyway love that world so yeah
again if i had more than four minutes
we'd be spending more time on that
let's just of course believe me i would
love to um jumping into
why i get to talk to you today did you
feel there's a i don't want to do any
spoilers but a lot of the movie takes
place obviously
on the train in the tunnel did you feel
like you were
sort of playing john mcclane at certain
points because
you know what i mean like that as i was
watching it i'm like oh he's making his
john mcclane movie
yeah yeah i mean definitely you know it
was i think
uh the forefront of uh of our thoughts
when especially when
um lawrence malcolm the writer was
writing it um
but yeah absolutely and you know then
add in a bit of bourne maybe a bit of
bond um it has kind of all of these
these links but
really i think it's coming it's kind of
more authentic than that you know we
it's based on andy mcnabb's
kind of experiences and him his book as
well so
uh and it's very much the world that we
live in you know it's set in
in the present day and this is how the
military and how the government operate
which is uh kind of terrifying
yeah one of the things that i took away
from the movie is that you can watch it
as a fun action thriller with really
good performances and great fight scenes
but there's also a subtext to this
script
dealing with like what's really going on
in the world that people sort of just
rush under the rug
it's really interesting i mean even
looking at what you know
dare i say you know what british special
interests are and how the military
employed
to go do that but they might be employed
for uh for other reasons maybe to
support
a big uh oil company or whatever it is
but yes this does go on and um
it is a very gray area and very great um
sort of
uh operating area that the military
um work in so uh yeah it's an eye opener
for me as well
what happens in your mind when the
director says to you we need to get this
in one take
um maybe a little bit like a psychopath
i sort of i feel the fear rising me and
then i just have to switch it off
and uh and suddenly become very calm
you're like okay what's going to be is
what it's going to be
and um i kind of enjoy that actually
it's it's almost like that jumping off
point when someone says action you know
you
you kind of know what's going to happen
but you also don't and i think uh
there's a real thrill in that to sort of
just see what happens
i got to go already i'm just gonna say
congrats on the movie and i hope you
guys get to make a sequel
i would love to watch it me too me too
we're definitely talking about it
thanks steven cool have a great day
youtube buddy thanks a lot mate